les gentils la date de notre télévision
à shawi entrepreneurs que nous faisons
une halte pas s'ils sont peu en deux et
bien il faut les chercher nicolas
ils ont dit qu'ils allaient au mexique
faut téléphoner au mexique à l'eau les
bixi qu on allait y aller avec ses gonds
mais non c'est la télévision du mexique
oui voulez vous n'avez pas vu un petit
nuage avec notre marchand de sable est
notre gros mots bourse
non c'est non non non vous devez le
ramener à 1 jean barbe au jardin oui
merci monsieur mexicain de la télévision
abandon d'ennahda
[Musique]
je n'arrive pas à me téléphoner aux gens
allô allô t'es mado d'ennahda monsieur
jaune à mes gars à qui pépite en
attendant on a vu qu'on fait nos moors
surchauffe avec le marchand de sable ou
mentaux non non non on est bien triste
titre je regarde le ciel le regard de
l'autre il ya beaucoup de nuages
tagro a pas un coquet qui a dit si nous
n'avons connaître voilà ce matin une
idée au téléphone directement marchand
de sable sans médaille à l'eau alors
allo c'est vous les enfants à l'eau nous
arrivons au bout en bout eu trop peur on
leur ville attend sa as
nous sommes au bord de faim enfin nous
revoilà votre ami nounours c'est
entièrement trompé de chemin avec ses
cartes de géographie
on ne pose du tout eu lieu au mexique
on s'est retrouvé à panama l'honneur le
port mais nous vous raconterons tout ça
demain
il est grand temps d'aller dormir on
accouche un petit marchand de sable et
on est très sage
à demain c'est promis rémy des enfants à
demain promis je donne au mauvais goût
allons vite nous coucher nounours bonne
nuit les petits faites de beaux rêves
bleus
[Musique]